experts tick tocks tic tacs where it's
like
and why aren't you in uniform and all
the little girls go and get in there
little cosplays
where in uniform
all right did i get oh hi
hello hello things and stuff bro
and crocodile jaws oh we're live
max conrad we're live with uh we're
already here
the these guys oh yeah what is this
three that's john
what is it there's a live stream oh you
guys are actually like in the live
stream
it's just
i'm looking at you right now i just want
to i just
[Music]
yeah oh wait we got you buddy yeah just
whatever the last thing you said was the
audio
jumped out i just want to make sure we
can hear you guys
you got 245 people watching you dude
warren
killing the 269. we earned you two
dislikes weren't
278 oh so one for you one for john i
the two dislikes i got
no what's up what's up everybody uh
super excited the real rejects
are here tonight greg and john two
awesome guys two
actual actual friends of mine they're
not just like other youtubers they're
actual friends
and uh it's everyone else there's just
other youtubers but we're real
exactly real we're not one of the crowd
we're family
[Music]
i was laughing aloud at your run of like
strong but not as strong as family ones
from earlier today
that's good they show up in the in end
games thanos is strong
but not a strong family stepping wolf is
strong
hey strive thanks for super chat and he
says what's up guys hi from canada
hi back to canada what up canada
yo what up bangladesh i use a vpn to
watch [ __ ] on your netflix
canada oh canada helps us out every week
yeah they do
yeah man it's amazing canada yeah
so what do you guys think's gonna happen
this episode
don't care i only pretend to be
interested
yeah that's my life juana's gonna read
from the dark hole
how do i okay
toby mcguire i'm gonna dub over you guys
i'm gonna like get somebody to dub over
you
well this episode is when they're gonna
you know like dealing with the other
three loki's that we saw before but
we might even see more loki's in just
those three but it's the one where it
has to be the episode with president
loki
right i i i think so i i think based off
everything we've seen
because you you would think that
it's kind of crazy because you don't
really know which direction it's going
to go but you would think
that like the final episode would be
like i'll call it a boss fight
right like if you have a video game or
something like that right
like you have a boss fight and you would
kind of think like that's
what it is so so i think all that
chaos stuff i don't know you think it
leads to like the final episode like it
all happens this episode and then
kind of the next episode is like finally
facing
the person in charge the tva gang uh
what
or miss minutes they're all going to
find this minute this minute is gonna
grow
these theories are yeah i mean there's
so much theories about that yeah what do
you guys think i mean
i bet i think this is gonna be the kind
of like michael waldron i think this
would be the episode
we don't he hasn't written like specific
he's not
solely credited as writer for it uh he's
a lot
he's the head writer but every episode
has had an individual staff writer
credited
what i'm hoping for is that this one
feels the most
michael waldron because of the fact that
you have the other loki's right
you can go crazy i'm really weirdly as
like as simple as it is i know where
it's cosmic wonder channel
we would talk about crazy plot points in
the future the mtu but
we never did honestly today what i'm
most excited for are just
character interaction yeah
we're going to be citadel of ricks yeah
that's what i'm at my home hoping it's
the most michael waldron episode yeah
yeah
yeah if we're going to do that i want it
to be like the craziest type of
interaction like funny but deconstructed
like i want it all there
imagine sorry go no go you're my guest
i mean no i'm the person who's gonna be
over here like no no you're the host
please
no you're like just go take it go
but because this is this has officially
been picked up for a second season right
yeah like i feel like in shows like one
division
is just for all intents and purposes its
own thing and then it's gonna feed into
doctor strange too whereas this is gonna
have a season two and so sometimes i
feel like in a show that's
intended and it knows it's going to
continue you'll almost get your boss
fight if there is one in an ultimate
episode and then the
final episode is all this sort of like
aftermath and setup for the future like
the emotional climax after the physical
climax
yeah yeah i don't know i'm i've learned
especially
the last episode to just expect the
unexpected so i don't know what to
expect
well here's here's a question i have for
you and i think
i i think you're right about expecting
the unexpected because didn't it um
tom hiddleston with uh in his interview
with comicbook.com brandon davis he said
didn't he say like ending a four
beginning of five or like five
like that's when things kind of get like
kind of crazy and he said like poor poor
loki
right but i mean there's gonna be a lot
so which one well didn't
five was his favorite or something did i
do that right
yeah yeah i think i i think that was a
quote that circulated somewhere so
and i mean i could see i could see this
being a paul bettany situation too where
it's like because i get to act against
myself but
even more right yeah i could definitely
be
do you think the president loki is a
variant or is that our location i've
been wondering
that for like a long time like is is it
i because he's like what did you expect
it's like okay that's like
the loki i know like he said it just
like that
i don't know but how would he go there
unless there's like a time jump in this
episode but i wouldn't expect the time
because in this universe everything is
decided democratically so
you can vanquish the tva we didn't pick
a leader loki
uh will be what uh i think there will be
a
like dominant loki i don't know if it'll
be him but i
because you know another theory that
actually chris came up with
is that you know the leader of the tva
is like
just the oldest loki right or like the
oldest variant loki
who's just figured out more than sylvie
and you know he's
the one that decided like i'm gonna
control everything because it's loki
right that's his whole deal he wants to
get in yeah
and mobius even says like why just rule
midgar like
what you know so maybe there's another
loki that's like yeah why just do that
like i'm gonna roll
every timeline everywhere no matter what
like you know
well is chris coining that theory
because i'm pretty sure i heard like a
bunch of other people make that theory
too
uh he came because he's on the spot
chris is down in the live stream so i
figured i could bag on him yeah all day
but i would i never i would never say
anything directly to it that's none of
my voice
you know i just i can't but i i talk bad
about everyone
but i can never say something to them
i'm nicely
i'm nice like that
[Laughter]
no that's a good that's honestly out of
all the theories that i've heard
i feel like we would we could get a kang
cameo
in this one i feel like it would be more
along the lines like thanos and avengers
assemble
yeah however or maybe
more longer than that however i think
for a
story purpose if we're just talking like
the future of the mcu
kang makes the most sense sure but in
terms of like telling just a damn good
season of television
i actually think another like the the
ultimate villain the one really pulling
the strings
is the old loki yeah yeah another
version of loki i feel like for like a
complete
story package of everything we've been
doing that would be the best one
but for like the future of the mcu we
got ravona rent slater ant-man
all that jazz right yeah i think uh kang
makes the most sense so
i'm opting for either one of those at
this point yeah kang or the loki who
remains
yeah yeah and real real quick let me
just acknowledge this super chat abe
from the sausage king of chicago you uh
always come into the super chats my
prediction is that president loki is a
variant in which
in which won the battle of new york and
caused such a nexus event that the tva
can't delete it
and just use it as purgatory good
content by the way hey thank you
um you know that that does seem to be
where they're at like a place where
loki maybe did win the battle remember
we see the tower it's all like destruct
it's like been destroyed and stuff like
that right right so maybe that's a good
theory
um oh it's out oh is it out
well before we dive into it i'll just
say i agree with you greg
and i think maybe like the post-credits
thing will be like well the person who
was really in charge of the tva was this
person named nathaniel richards or
something like that you know what i mean
yeah something something brief like that
yeah but i am wondering i want to make
one little
prediction before do it you hop into
your watch along because we got to film
our reaction
right um
the family doesn't lie guys do this
every week you say it's not when it's
not anyways go
we can stay here longer okay good let me
get back to chris for a second that guy
wow
like what is up with that dude
yeah okay so the um
because in the trailer when he says like
what did you expect when he's president
loki
yeah doesn't everyone turn on him yeah
so what if there is a president
or something of that nature and then our
loki tries to
take over that mantle and disguise
himself as that
because he looks enough
and that's why everyone takes so that's
why everyone turns on him i don't know
i'm trying it's about
my thing in the trailers why does
everyone turn on him
yeah absolutely they're all you know
sorry go ahead
under his thumb or let him talk it's
history
i talk and then talks i think you wait
it's still surreal to see you while
hearing your voice speak so whenever you
speak to me i'm like oh my goodness you
know
i'm sorry i don't even remember what i
was gonna say
um oh no to john's point i
what if there is like leadership that
has formed within the loki's
that just seems to make sense right
because who knows how long they've been
there their variants right and
time i don't know if that like limbo
world exists
in time out of time you know because the
tva is not in time
so it's like i don't know what it's like
there how long has it been there
um but you have to imagine if there's a
lot of loki's and
there's a plan someone has to take
charge especially if you're there for
years we'll call it years if time exists
you know so maybe there's a leader
and to john's point maybe you took over
that leader's position
and tried to sneak attack everybody
how would he take over so soon that's
what i mean it's like they're going to
be a time jump in this episode or
something one who are the other people
the other thing i've what is time
greg who are the other construct
time is omnipresent but who are the
other people who turn on him because
they don't look like loki's
i think well they're both of them yeah
no yeah i think they're lucky variants
they are located so they're just looking
variants who don't look at all like tom
hiddleston
it's like when we saw the loki variants
at the post-credits scene of the last
episode
gotcha yeah i think yeah i mean this
[ __ ] you don't see in a real region well
because
because because i'm sitting here because
i'm sitting here thinking of the montage
in the tva
where the frost giant loki looks like
tom hiddleston
the tour de france loki looks like tom
hiddleston they all yes
the hulk one they all look like him well
what if
there was a liar he's a loki variant
everyone's a loki very important let's
just jump
it all in let's just throw it off andrew
garfield
oh i have coined the variant uh
uh what was it andrew mcguire
nice i think i made that that's like the
first watch party for loki i was like
yeah and then andrew mcguire comes in
and
everybody's like hashtag andrew mcguire
i think i tweeted it too
instead of uploading a breakdown
tomorrow you should just upload another
spider-man
i think that's right i don't think
people got enough yet i think they're
like
i need like three people keep asking for
more
your update should be i had a thought
here's one here's my thought
thought that i had about rhino
guys back to rhino thanks for the super
chat how does scarlet witch tie him with
the tva spider-man
your chat is going bananas saying it's
out so is that
okay uh it it probably is now because
usually when everybody's spamming it's
out it's out
journey into mystery 58 minutes
who has that much time mine says 50
minutes we do
15 minutes 5-0 oh
i was hoping for 15 minutes
that would have been a great breakdown i
know
dave you got your [ __ ] out in like an
hour i want an adult swim
cartoon loki all right loki is
it out on our end you know what screw
we're not going to film our reaction
we're just going to be here with you
yeah we'll just watch it live and that's
the reaction and then we will capitalize
on the review after
we'll wait for all the things your chat
has to say and then we will just say it
in our heart
and then be like yep these are all our
own original thoughts
here you go and just do it that way i'm
assuming you're kidding
but feel free to
well all right cool thanks so much guys
uh
it's always awesome to have you on wish
you could have you here for the whole
thing but of course you got to film your
reaction everybody say thank you to real
rejects
and if you're not subscribed to them go
subscribe right now thank you
thank you stop all right stop stop stop
stop
stop they're getting too much praise
they're going to believe you
keep a lookout on your phone maybe i'll
get so excited by the end i'll be like
let me hop on just to tell you for five
seconds how awesome this
sounds good all right all right guys
[Laughter]
see you guys all right that was a real
rejects and now it's time to watch loki
everybody ready because we starting it
all right
where the heck is it why is it all right
we're starting in three
two one i cannot show it that big that
is not gonna work i will get
sued
trusting this man is not a good idea i
can handle him tva
has pruned a lot of these guys and no
two are
oh mobius please
no why make me relive that
all right who created tva please tell me
this episode
please tell me this episode
no
please freaking tell me this episode ah
here we are
all right he wakes up
[Music]
hi level three what up
it's time for the uh good old energy
drink of the day
episode name is journey into something
journey into mystery it is 15 minutes
long
and we are watching it right now
uh new haircut no more like i napped
before this
and i don't know i covered all of the
headset but thank you
oh i did get a new haircut like a couple
weeks ago though so if you weren't here
last
last week all right here we go
logo just uh got done and we are at the
tva
i'll just show you guys all the good
parts
excuse me
we're still just at the tva i give you
guys a little bit bigger screen than
that right a little time a bit bigger
stop spinning i'm like
it's still spinning i'm still like
all right where are we at
some people are uh a little ahead of me
i need to
i can't read the chat right now oh that
is a
creepy looking man all right here we go
this seems to be the loki world
that we're going into this limbo of a
world which i
if you caught one of my videos i talked
about how kang
kind of rules the limbo world and that's
where chronopolis is in limbo and the
limbo dimension which is where i think
they
are uh but i don't think we'll see kang
until like the post credits of like the
final episode
i don't think he's gonna be the main
villain i think it's gonna be
i think he's behind it but not like the
main focus you know
all right here we are loki is uh getting
picked up by the other loki's let's hear
what he has to say
what is this place
goliath
no way
oh no way
no way oh no
yes
give me a temp pad
who's really behind the tba
thanks isaiah richardson for that chat
for that super chat
well she's getting her butt kicked
i can't really hear them
i don't care if it's complicated tell me
liar she wants to know who lied to her
liar
when move it on a place in the timeline
where it won't
grow anymore
the end of time is still being written
the dogma states
dude i freaking love her she's awesome
uh f bull i'm so sorry yeah that's when
we started uh that's when we started
going
um i think the nexus event that was
mentioned in um one division wow
uh the nexus event is going to be a huge
event that happens that's going to have
a big impact in multiverse of madness
and that and the nexus events that they
talk about here
that's how they all tie into each other
i'm so sorry i'm glad i looked at the
chat and saw that though uh
thank you for that super chat oh look at
this it's so cool
we've got to keep moving so we don't die
what's your plan don't die
there's a little ton of birds and and
someone please explain what's going on
plus an alligator look at that
oh snap kid loki just
dang
dude kid loki's freaking a baller
it's a place where all the everything
they prune timelines everything goes
and eliath
we're in a shark tank eliath is the
shark
the alligators are low-key too
[Laughter]
i'm willing to accept that
all arrested by the tba improved
there is survive that's all we can do
dang just do what you want
mr anderson already kicking butt
oh no kid loki's nexus event
oh spoiler guys we talked about spoilers
in here so spoiler
luke the kid loki's next event was that
he killed thor
holy crap so the classic loki richard he
grant
the thanos copter no way
look at that
classic freaking comic
thanos copter dude
just diving into their little thor's
hammer
frog thor no way
they put so much into this
you leave your glorious purpose at the
tva dude they put so much
that's amazing
freaking throg look at this oh there it
is there's a loki palace
oh she's talking to miss minutes
this minutes is working magic
what if there's something beyond the
void
is
go through the void
there's a void spacecraft
oh rinse layers saying that they're
going to kill the person behind the tva
together
okay
uh it was a trap you
[Music]
she took the temp pad
i freaking love sir
talk about it
oof do you have any good memories that's
rude
killer killer
oh what is about to happen oh she's gone
she's gonna go ham
oh she got herself sweet
sweet
that's awesome that's bold move
oh you liar you liar she's not dead you
know where she went
roxy won oh it's from that timeline
this guy killed iron man captain america
all six stones
oh look at that
this is great oh i love it
me i want to hear your story please tell
me
oh they don't know who thanos is or
maybe they do
until thanos attacked our ship
oh
[Laughter]
deck
dang this is intense
so he didn't get stabbed by thanos he
cast an illusion
extremely real
i got lonely oh he missed his brother
uh this episode is 50 minutes long
the god of outcasts
it's kind of mean god of outcasts
still kid look he was drinking a high
seed juice boxed
oh kid loki says you're different why
have you met a woman variant of us she's
different she's terrifying
goliath is what keeps us here
if it lives it dies they're going to
kill elia
they're going to say nope yeah they're
gonna laugh at him
kid loki is hilarious
it's a cool little hangout that they got
you're hearing my audio
guys we talk about spoilers in the chat
so and then this and i show the screen
so hey look other loki's
he's not president loki look at that
there's a lot more lookers
ah sylvie
you can hear my audio can everybody else
hear my audio
um
uh i don't know how you can hear it i
really don't that's that's weird
what about now here now oh snap what
just happened
she's move she just moved through
something weird
oh that's gotta be mobius
that's gotta be mobius
it is freaking mobius
it is freaking mobius
look at that crab i love it
sonny's pizza there's no way this does
not end
with him on a jet ski
you really are one of you that's
hilarious there's the sphinx
in the comics that's king's uh
spacecraft
oh president loki with other variants of
loki
oh brother lucky expect it it portrayed
them
so they're not okay
so everybody's betraying everybody
he's a low-key why is there an alligator
he's a loki
oh snap he's like
dude although all the low-keys are
fighting
oh magic
[Laughter]
oh projections what
oh wow that guy's yeah that classic
loki's magic really is super intense
oh he opened a portal
uh
we can't change all
we're broken that's not nice
oh they want to be good they just can't
okay we'll help you because they're
going to try to save sylvie
approaching alive is a death sentence
we totally scanned gator loki potato
[Music]
oh
all right
oh i'm obvious don't beat yourself up
test this is better
i think the microphone volume is what
was letting the
audio in a little bit
well here we go guys
should be better now right
yeah sophia di martino is beautiful
she's gorgeous
turn around go back to the angry cloud
we're going back to it sweet that's
where everybody's going to meet up
and mobius is going to get his freaking
jet ski probably on this episode it's
definitely going to be at the end of
whoa that looked like a giant loki
find its heart or its brain or whatever
and get it
what does kid loki have in his hand he's
prick
alligator look at his brain he thinks
we're gonna die
okay oh the people are on it too
kid look he has something in his his
hand i don't know what it is
that's pretty funny you're trying to
shoot
a cloud and they're destroyed there
i think you can hear my audio through my
headset in some weird way
maybe we uh get a better plan here is he
alligator logi is an actual thing
i can't show full screen because i'll
get copyrighted for it
it's over reunion
kiss kiss i i want it i don't care how
weird it is
i don't care where it is
i love this so much
how to put this me us
as a child us in the future and as
an alligator that's hilarious
what was happening but
she's gonna enchant the guard dog
interesting
all right hold on we're back to
rensslayer
leave us leave who missed minutes all
right let's see what the freaking deal
is
bust out nathaniel richards come on
kang king i actually don't really think
we'll see him to like the extreme
end but she's about to look at something
dude she's she's pulling out her tent
pad and she's gonna bring somebody in
oh freaking a it's her come on
i thought you were about to show me
freaking jonathan majors
you were just loyal to the tva
the changes
you need to tell me everything
interesting
who created timekeepers come on tell me
this isn't about protecting the tva it's
about protecting your boyfriend king
oh he says she she wants to find out
who's behind it too
she needs it i knew it i could write
stuff
not really this is amazing
so ren slayer wants to figure out who
created the tva as well because she
doesn't know
she's getting all the files in the
creation of the tva
okay back in limbo
i don't remember alligator logan mobius
doesn't remember alligator loki
it's always the game within the game
which i respect
well mobius wants to tell people the
truth
oh it's never too late to change mobius
says
why do i feel like freaking alligator
loki's gonna be the freaking goat
look he says mobius isn't so bad or good
that's why we get along
come on loki tell her you love her tell
your love yourself you tell you you love
yourself
it's confusing
oh the tension i feel the tension
guys talk about something come on
oh don't brush stuff as rubbish
it's not another tv a lot you love each
other come on
you could freaking feel the sexual
tension between
two people who are the same person
i don't know how to do this i don't know
what we're doing
[Laughter]
saving the universe no need to be
dramatic but yeah kind of
just tell each other you love each other
come on oh we put the blanket around her
too it's so cute
oh
it's not very snuggling
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
do something fam
how do i know in the final moments you
won't betray me
[Music]
and he knows why he betrayed everybody
else
and why he did it but that's not who he
is anymore
i won't let you down i really hope
silvia doesn't let us down
i really hope sylvia doesn't betray our
guy
there might be a timeline for you to
rule
it could be loki that's it could be loki
that's behind it
like some big king loki it's behind
everything
you never know
when it's all over maybe we could figure
it out together
how cute just do it come on
what the heck are these things little
chirpy guys
what are those things they have floating
balsa says oh that's epic
that might be my thumbnail for tomorrow
that's a crazy cool shot
ass i freaking love it
i'm telling you alligator loki is gonna
save one of the other loki's
he's gonna sacrifice himself
oh she linked to it when it hit her
earlier
and she saw something
come on oh she's giving him the temp pad
that's big that's big that's big that's
big
she trusts him that's why she
oh look he's going with sylvie
how cute i hope they show kang but i
i don't know if it's
oh
oh this is our home
all the other locations are going to
stay
oh he gave him a magical dagger
expecto patronum more like avada kadabra
all right all right
hope you find what you're looking for
let's frickin do the please don't end
how much longer is left the episode
yeah we got time we got time we got time
you got away in the end i always do
what will you do at the tva burn it to
the ground
let's frickin do it
oh come on hug him
hug him yeah
oh yeah oh look at that
he caught him his friend
that's crazy cool oh i freaking love
that i freaking love that
that's so great i love that oh that's a
freaking lit scene too
good luck sylvie
there's goliath that thing's a beast
these guys aren't done they're gonna go
fight they're gonna fight
guys i think i think this trio of loki
sylvian mobius has become my favorite
trio
in the mcu so far that tt
what is it eating i can't even tell
it's eating something oh
that's intense these guys are freaking
great
he stands behind her
cause of destruction oh that's that's a
great pick right there
that's epic i love it
and here goes our loki
oh she's trying to chant it and here he
goes
use your wand yeah here we go
ah look at that
love it i
freaking love it love it i was gonna say
i low-key it which i do low-key it
this is intense this is intense
oh that's awesome
oh it's looking at her
oh it's gonna be classic loki using
magic it's gonna be classic loki oh
no way he's building a whole city with
his magic
oh my gosh look at that oh he built
asgard
look at that
i think we're stronger than we realize
oh that's so freaking cool
go wow
look at that he created a asgard wow
yeah hold hands yes i love it
we're going to enchant it
oh
look at wow look at that oh it's fake
son it's fake son loki got you he
located you
that's insane that's insane
get him get him get him get him
oh they held hands even harder
do it loki enchant it
no classic look he's weak
save classic loki
somebody save classic loki
no
come on come on come on what you doing
glorious purpose
come on they're gonna kill og loki oh
no
no and that's gonna be the end i bet
oh come on freaking come on
come on loki's yes
no way
they did it
open your eyes
i love this music what are we seeing
what are we seeing what are we saying
help the
just the fact that they did it
is that it
look at that wow
okay okay okay okay go go go go go go go
oh wow
oh man
so there is no in credit scene
there isn't there's nothing
no no in credit saying
wow
wow what an episode
oh i'm like
that was freaking epic oh man i love
that episode for so many different
reasons
so many different reasons i love that
episode
oh man that's freaking amazing
that's so crazy
i did it
[Music]
maybe
oh man that uh
that's definitely the best episode so
far
they always gotta kill the freaking og
though
dude i was literally like oh i don't
think anyone can hear you yet hold on
there we go talk hello everybody
there we go that was a fun episode i had
fun watching that episode
yeah um i can't tell you how many times
i was like kiss
kiss kiss kiss during that whole scene i
was straight like an anime girl
yeah right yeah uh super dude thanks for
the super chat that's what i was
thinking i was looking at that castle
when i was looking at the sky
um i was thinking yeah maybe it could be
quantum city
kind of that's what i thought too that
was my first impression
actually my real first impression was
the bad guys professor x and it's uh the
x mansion for school for gifted
youngsters yeah right that was my honest
first thought i was like oh it's
professor x
imagine i think i would
just throw it in there like it's just
like
still no big reveal or even a little
reveal or anything
i uh i'm really like
i don't think we're going to see kang i
think he's behind it
but i don't think we're going to see him
uh so you double down on kang and i've
doubled down on it's low-key
i double down i definitely i definitely
think that that has its merits obviously
oh i'm the same way and i've said that
in
almost every video i've done or
statement i've made about it
yeah i said warren thinks it's kang i
think it's loki but quite frankly like
there is enough evidence that i would
believe king i wouldn't be surprised or
disappointed if it was king i just i
really i'm going to double down on loki
just to
that's where i'm headed i don't know
that's just yeah that's what i'm going
with
mk gaming by moonish thanks for that um
are we at the theme song super chat
chronopolis that's the quantum realm i
mean it
i want to say yes uh
ismail montoya thanks for super chat
what's behind the portal panopoulos
ah so the only thing is is that it's it
doesn't seem like a city it seems like a
castle uh like a stream
yeah it seems like a stronghold um
you know so i don't know if it is the
quantum city definitely the sky looks
like it could be but it also looks like
they could be just in the middle of
space because you know time that's the
end of time right it's like technically
like
there's something beyond the void which
is like as far as time goes
so and that was the whole like
it was the one thing i thought when it
was all talked about that and we did
finally see her
um oh my gosh i'm blanking on her name
but judge
ritzler please help me uh yeah rinse
doesn't know who it is so she's not
king's lover at the moment
yeah i don't know i don't believe her uh
maybe i guess
um i mean she was alone yeah i guess
taylor hendricks thanks for the super
chat love this episode alexa look
especially
but what are the actual chances still
being looking up together
they're probably gonna kiss and then
part ways in all honesty i mean
as much as i hate that
i feel that that's what's going to
happen
i feel like they're gonna like kiss and
have a really nice touching
moment something's gonna happen and then
they're gonna but then they'll part ways
um
do you think well that was my my
question now do you think both of them
make it out of here
alive i think both make it out i'm gonna
i'm gonna legitimately cry if sylvie
dies
well i think maybe loki dies and then
sylvia becomes loki moving forward in
in battle wars when that all ends up
happening and that's how the loki
reconnects and loki's out for a little
bit
maybe yeah um trevzal thanks for another
super chat
always coming to clutch each week he
just said something that i'm going to
have to screenshot on my phone
uh
oh it's going to take an eternity
spelled out
kang k k-q-e-n-g on adventures tower
at three minutes in and uh kevin hdz
yeah
freaking the thanos copter man did you
catch that chris
i did see the thanos
i can't remember the name of the hammer
but um remember the name of the
character no not milner the other one
throg that uh yeah yeah yeah was in it
in the background as well there's gonna
be so many uh he wasn't in the
background it's like when they were
shift like shifting from above ground
underground the camera was doing that
they showed him there he was trying to
grab mjolnir yeah
which he was in a bottle which is funny
pretty cool
yeah um
yeah how to join my discord how do i go
back i just i can't take a screenshot
i need to get all my links in a place so
i don't have to go in yeah chris
come on i'm not organized ladies and
gentlemen just accept it i'm not either
it's okay so okay that yeah to me that
looks like that really does look like
it it could be in the quantum realm
and you know it doesn't look like how i
thought it would look it threw me a
little off there's definitely
some huge castle but the inside could
look completely different who who knows
right because if you're yeah
yeah we've seen what the tva
whoever has created the tva has created
right they have created the tva
clearly they can kind of do whatever
they want
like yeah they can change whatever they
need to however they need to
yeah so
inside's probably a lot different um and
that's probably just
you know the outside appearance but um
i still i i i think it's i think it's
king or i think it's loki
um i've seen a few people say doom yeah
i mean doesn't it look like doom castle
i mean
i just can't imagine if they would
throw him in so soon and uh
i just i i can't imagine it would be
doom you know i
uh
[Music]
i mean it's i just don't see how it
could be doomed but i guess you know
it's god emperor dream from battle world
i guess i mean this is that could be the
connection this is the problem i think
it's just
yeah it would be so crazy for them to
just drop dudes just like that
yeah unless and you know we're not
getting fantastic four anytime soon
but no we're not cause it's just it's
too much
too much too early wouldn't be too much
yeah isaiah i would love to see it
i wouldn't not now well no like i would
love to see doom
yeah i mean it would be really close he
wouldn't fit into the story of what's
going on it would just be
so much so quickly the only big reveal
for the future of the mcu that makes
sense at all
yeah uh zay richardson thanks for the
super chat these disney plush shows
always show the villain
was here all along aka agatha it's
looking more like a loki variant or
rent slayer since there's only one
episode left
i am very upset about one thing very
important in this episode that needs to
be discussed right now
a huge missed opportunity why did mobius
not
go and rescue sylvie on a jet ski
because there's no water there could
have been they could have
they made the set yeah
imagine he comes rolling in she's
running next to a like an ocean or a
lake and
he comes rolling in on a jet ski and
then she says and
she goes wow she says it instead so he
sees the cloud and then he goes
wow wow get on jonathan i know you
missed opportunity
i think we're going to get it though
jonathan granados remember
in lucky previews there was a scene of
loki and destroyed castle like asgard
the scene hasn't happened think it's the
original loki
yeah i'm thinking it's uh
[Music]
i so here's what i think could happen i
think
man you know if it's not kang it's loki
i i don't think
those are the options for me i i think
those are my options i think if it's
i think if it's not kang it's loki
here's my here's my deal
kang's confirmed for the future
right jonathan mages is playing kang
he's coming in ant-man on the wasp
quantum medium
uh and you know what maybe
maybe the quant maybe chronopolis is in
the quantum realm
and that was the city that we saw but
maybe that's just a completely different
thing maybe the tva isn't in the quantum
realm
yeah and this is just literally a
different outside of space and time
type of thing yeah and that that's just
waiting for the fantastic four later on
who knows
yeah i mean
[Music]
yeah uh ismael montoya where where did
mobius go he went back to the tva
headquarters so
his last words well one of his last
words where he's gonna burn it to the
ground
so he still look his words oh my gosh i
loved
that scene when they said goodbye oh
because he put out his hand i was like
hug him lookie and he hugs him and he
calls him his friend and he says you're
my favorite
loki's actually changed loki's
legitimately changed
which is interesting because um
i was wondering how are they going to
how they were going to do that like
because the loki that
changed that we saw went through all
these things and i'm like well this
loki is looking they just tried to take
over um
you know new york and rule the earth and
i was like you know that's
he's gonna have to go through a lot to
really change he has
right and he has he's he's crazy crazy
couple days
like he said yeah uh uh one sec i got a
super chat
from jabber27 says sending love your way
doesn't seem like you get as much love
as warren
thank you jeff i love chris very much
warren loves me all the way i
love him everybody show love to chris at
cosmic culture
if you can open up another tab or leave
my tab
and go to cosmic culture and subscribe
to him
and spam his chat it's not too nice do
it i'll
show you i'll show you all how to do it
right now
everybody go do it you pull up a tab
you go to youtube.com
oh man you watch all my k-pop pop-up
warren watches a ton of k-pop i watch so
much k-pop i can't confuse you
cosmic culture you click on the watch
party
no i don't want to add chris nobody dude
back to the place
and then you go watch chris and me on
there
as well and then spam the chat
it's alternate reality i'm alternate
reality
bam i did it bam yeah auggie thanks for
joining man
uh c-o-m-g it's john did you catch the
fallen avengers tower
that's something written on the side
thank you for joining everybody um
apparently
what it said on the side was q-e-n-g
yeah which could i saw it right like a
weird
king uh who knows about that
so i mean obviously i'm going to go
through this and like dissect every
little
little thing
i think the villain is
is loki and sylvia's kid kane
is that are you trying to say king
because i don't i don't think i know a
cane
a lion eliath guards king's kingdom in
the comics
shane martin photo yeah because it's uh
you know when you sit there in um
limbo i always forget the name of that
dimension
your windows open what happened
i'm just reading i'm like in and out of
meeting myself so i don't disrupt you as
well
um so we have a final episode coming up
ward
yes personally i don't feel like it's
enough time
but i mean they always do a decent job
of wrapping up i think falcon in the
winter soldier was wrapped up pretty
well
i think one division was wrapped up very
well but we have one episode left
a huge reveal of whoever this big bad is
and then
how everything ends don't you mean wow
wow and if it does not end in a
post-credit with that happening wow
i'll be very upset but um
[Music]
how you know realizing we haven't seen
the end so far
how does this make you feel for the
future of disney plus shows you know we
have hawkeye coming with she-hulk
this is a really really cool series um
it's by far the best to me um
look this show is the best to me um i i
couldn't really decide between wanda
vision and falcon and winter soldier uh
because they were very
different i felt like neither of them
like i felt like i don't know i just
feel like they're
i couldn't decide and but this one to me
is a clear winner like this series
like is it even that last scene where
classic loki like creates the illusion
of freaking
asgard that was epic i was losing my
mind i was like wow
i mean well and i love the response too
it's like how is he doing that and it's
it's just like i think we're stronger
than we think and it's 100
you know these loki characters and loki
even just loki from the avengers was
his potential was just never met because
his his whole ideology of what he should
be was so clouded by
his own arrogance that he never really
did become who he was and that's
something that classic loki got through
because he did realize there's more than
glorious purpose he said it multiple
times like scoffing with glorious
purpose
he got past that he did reach his full
potential so that was super cool to see
it was cool to see and um
yeah get to get that get that camera
else right now working on it and uh
and triv saying uh what do you think the
weed budget was for this episode no way
they wrote that stuff without being on
substances
right yeah at least uh at least uh at
least like 10 grand right
there's like one person on set that's
like required to always bring like weed
to them
at some point that's funny thanks thanks
for that super chat
uh monster js26
oh wait so king loki has yet to be seen
is he really behind this i don't think
they would show that in the trailer
it's either kang or king loki behind it
yeah that's that's what i think um
here's the deal is there's a lot of
connections to kang
uh eliath uh the limbo dimension
um uh ravana ren slayer like there's the
just the whole time aspect like there's
so many
things connecting it to kang i i would
be shocked if it wasn't battery
exhausted
uh-oh matthew king what is going on my
guy what do you
think was that city they showed us at
the end um
a lot of people said it looked like doom
castle i'm gonna agree it definitely
look like doom castle don't think it's
doom castle
i i think it's um i think it's either
a castle where we'll call him king loki
resides or it's uh chronopolis it's
it's kang uh lone wolf what's up thanks
for the super chat so at
18 13. we'll still be slightly in
chancel
if you pause in that scene you'll see
the front of the castle with two hour
glasses
at the entrance if that's true then
that's that's
king what was it i missed it sorry uh
1813.
wait 1813. in the in the movie
in the show oh right right because she
sees
because she like touches it yeah
uh it's not white 1813 oh no
maybe it is playing i think
yeah so oh that kind of does look like
the freaking quantum
there are two yeah there are hourglasses
in front of it
[Music]
and then when you get dang it i want it
like
it like goes to one of the hard paws
it's so fast yeah it gets it gets to one
of the towers
and yeah that's that's interesting
thanks for that infinity shades thanks
for that awesome super chat
the castle the end kind of looked like
the hydra base at the start of the
avengers age of ultron also i think
mjolnir that we will see come to our
location final moment showing that
loki's worthy yeah how sweet would that
be
because i think our loki is becoming
worthy you know
zam master artwork are we not going to
talk about the giant statue head of
living tribunal
when they are about to fight that smoke
thing you know i i
i was trying to number it looked like
there was more than three though
you know was was there was there
oh the faces yeah was it i couldn't make
it out
or you know was it uh um
you know i'll have to look at that uh
eric morgan long time listener first
time
caller i'm not late that we already
covered the thanos copter yeah how cool
was that right
like to take something from the comics
and freaking so
i'm surprised i didn't see squirrel girl
in there right i mean
i mean she might be there somewhere well
that's classic thanos
yeah thanks uh eric morgan for that
super chat yeah isn't that super cool
jake says there's no one going to bring
up how shady miss minutes was the whole
episode she knows all
this minutes is up to something maybe
she's dependent maybe
uh i mean i i wouldn't be surprised if
like miss minutes is controlled by
it's left right right exactly i don't
think it's a living being
isaiah richardson jr another super chat
thank you classic loki gave us a spoiler
he said
he created a duplicate of himself so
real that thanos nor thor knew it
our main loki may still be alive yeah
and
maybe that loki has kind of started to
realize some of his potential
uh jonathan grah nadas
granted us sorry uh season two confirmed
have to be story they can continue not
big villain every season
look it makes sense because that's how
season one end and they continue loki's
story
season two yeah i mean i i can't really
argue with the theory that it's loki
behind it right and it would be a loki
thing to freaking do right so i mean
wouldn't
it it'd be a super lucky thing to do
so yeah uh bradley jones thank you for
that super chat hang made sacred
timeline
waiting to strike that's why tony steve
thanos loki are all gone
as they could pose a threat to him steve
is on the moon yeah i mean that could be
that could totally be an option as well
right i mean
it really could alexa what's up every
week coming in clutch
i'm enjoying these watch parties me too
great job ah thank you
can it be that tv8 rinse later is a
variant of the king's lover that's why
she doesn't have a memory
i think is king but we only get a hint
of him so that's what i'm kind of
thinking
too i'm kind of thinking that i don't
think we're gonna really like
see kane well i don't know because
here's the deal here's the deal
they're gonna go into that castle uh
that's where we're gonna go
pick right up the next episode they're
gonna get in that castle and there's
somebody at the top of that castle
and they're gonna confront that person
is it a variant of rin slayer is it a
loki variant
is it king we're gonna have to wait and
see i
i think just because of all the evidence
and all the connection to kang so far
ravana renslayer uh the timekeepers
which in the comics the timekeepers
actually come to kang
and they kind of tell him like hey we're
the final beings of time like the very
end of time which they talk about
in the show like that uh that void is
like the end of time time has been
written yet
um they the timekeepers come in they say
we're the
last three beans and you know instead of
destroying timelines and conquering them
kang how about you save some
and in return will make you immortal
then he becomes the character a mortis
and i think you know there's big
connections there obviously with the
timekeepers and everything like that
um and then you have
uh eliath which is a huge king
connection now and this limbo dimension
that they're in which is where
chronopolis is
in the uh in the comics so
i i think there's just so much there uh
the gamer thanks for the super chat
classic loki said he full thanos look
he's live i i hope so
uh i hope so man yeah um so i just think
i just think man there's just so
many connections to kang it'd be crazy
if
if
it wasn't him robert soriano switched
between kang and the loki not wanda
mummy's bracelet
right or it's a loki villain and king
will show up for like
seconds like in the middle of 2012.
that's kind of what i'm thinking is
going to happen um
like it's going to be like a thanos
cameo and we're going to start to build
it up like that right
let's see um jay london the big yellow
stone at the top of the castle the end
looks like the mine stone
i'll have to look into that a little bit
more um
do i still have that part saved i do
still have that part saved let's
click right yeah
yellow stone uh maybe it looks really
big
uh is the only thing because i think
nothing looks really big so we'll have
to see about that
um but thank you for that super chat
um chris has audio he just mutes himself
sometimes to
talk you're just answering a ton of
super chats so i was just letting you
roll on whenever you're done let me know
we roll
no ag official hope it's loki if it's
king it won't be mad
chris you're sticking out you're
sticking a loki
i'm sticking with loki i have i've said
it since episode
two or three i i figure like if i jump
ships now and it is i'll be just
so here's my add-on to that
is if we think about
how the other shows have gone
they've kept it really focused on the
title that's one of my
big points loki is about loki
and we're we're in a show about variants
so
my whole my whole argument for loki and
i'm sure you know it it's
the exact same thing you just said it's
a show about
loki and that's been the disney plus
kind of mantra up to this point
then you have you know the loki's all
hate each other and the big change in
the plot and the nexus event is by like
loki liking itself so obviously the
reason all these loki's are causing
problems in the timeline is because of
loki's in charge and that's all
this reason why mobius has to be the
head detective studying loki's and
making sure there is no problem with
them i think it's just a lot of stuff
lines up
again 100 believe everything you say
about kang as well
like i don't necessarily think it isn't
kang i just i'm sticking with lucky for
my pick
well regardless kang's coming he's
coming in ant-man and
in the lost quantum mania
he's coming right the question is is he
behind
this well the one thought i had in this
episode was it's possible that kang
you know he's in pretty intense being
but if like loki says the tva is the
most
formidable force in the universe maybe
kang's laying low because he's aware of
the tva he's aware of all that
and when loki and sylvia actually end up
taking down the tva then kane can rank
free and that'll be the post-credits
scene
him watching from afar the tva being
taken apart and then
something demonstrating it's go time for
him maybe uh
priyanshu gosh thanks for the super chat
um the whole
the tpa actually well here's the thing
it would be a little bit of a twist to
make king behind the tva
because in the comics he goes up against
the tva but he always beats the tva
they they don't do it very good the tva
and the comics are actually very clumsy
when it comes to king yes uh bradley
wagenstein thanks for the super chat the
topic no aj thank you for the super chat
i appreciate it man it looks similar
to the prune ones oh yeah it kind of
does
interesting no way g dropped in from
your chat
showed me some love too hey what up yeah
that's
uh that's that's an interesting one uh
it did kind of look like the
because it's in a tower and it has that
light on it so yeah
let's talk okay chef
what's a custom design there's a lot to
think about in this in this episode
um well it's because we didn't get a lot
of answers right so we kind of have to
make them up
that's what we do that's it that's what
we do
and sometimes we're wrong and sometimes
we're right
and uh thank you gambit yeah yeah hey
green guruji thanks for that super chat
um modern ignorance we've yet to see a
scene from one of the most recent
trailers where loki stands for 48
episodes
yeah um
and we've actually seen yeah we've seen
the scene where loki is like going
through the hallway
um
so here's my only thing
to finish my thought on that yeah we've
we've seen a scene where loki kind of
goes through the hallway and his ass
guardian outfit i actually have it on my
phone right here let me take a look
he starts off in his tva outfit because
he's wearing a tv out of here he's
walking through like these grand halls
it's clearly the cast on the class
castle on the inside clearly is but in
it it looks like time is kind of shatter
or like
the reality is like kind of shattering
so
here's here's my question like look he
realizes that he's
you know more powerful than he imagines
but the ultimate question is
at any point in time is he strong enough
or powerful enough to create the tva
to create oh big question
what oh man i just thought of a call
back to the first episode
when loki's like i know what this is
it's an illusion what if it is an
illusion by loki
what if the whole tva really was an
illusion a very elaborate illusion from
loki himself
oh no it's difficult to put it into
like because all of these facts like
you're saying
do actually add up like any one of these
threads makes sense
yeah so any one of these actually do
make like clear and obvious i'm not
making assumptions i'm not guessing like
right factual evidence sense so at the
end of the day whatever ends up
happening it's going to be exciting
i personally do believe that loki as a
character
has the potential and the power to
run the tva i think
like you said kang could have taken down
the tva a long time ago and killed the
time keep the the time
keepers the time watchers and made
himself in charge of it
either one of those options are a
hundred percent option a hundred percent
positive pot possible
sorry man you know i
i'm not sure loki is hey agrian guruji
thanks again for another super chat
i i i don't know if loki is that strong
um
[Music]
cause like we were talking about what
two two two episodes or last episode ago
um there's a handful of people who are
strong enough to do this in the mcu
a handful right and because you have to
think about what actually
is happening it
or what's happening sorry happening i
know to speak i promise i do it for a
living
uh you have to think about what's
actually happening like
i don't think the tva could be an
illusion although maybe they could have
just simply put that in the very first
episode
but think about what the tv actually
does they actually
control time can loki control time
can loki come up with magic that
controls
well that was the thought i was i mean i
guess at one i guess in episode
three when they're trying to get on the
ship the thing falls he stops the thing
and reverses time
uh he didn't have the time stone right
uh i mean this whole thing again just
like with one division and the falcon of
the winter soldier is loki realizing his
power
and his ability character has been
sidelined essentially in the mcu because
he's never had his own time to shine he
was a villain he was a good guy
just like with again wanda and falcon
so he is realizing and learning all
these new powers there's no question
that
both of the other characters ended their
series more powerful than they started
it
sure especially like scarlet witch wanda
like that's a whole different thing i
can't wait to see you too
is it that far like could loki ever be
that powerful
to create such an organization that
controls time that controls
nexus events and deletes timelines and
puts everything into one
it creates time jumping right
and i don't see that and i don't see
that i see kang the
master of time being able to do that um
but then again kang has no superpowers
the only thing about him is he's a
genius and he's from the future
right so if he learns i mean the
avengers figured out time travel too you
know
that's true uh gameboy 98 love the name
i'm calling it kang
comic thanos or loki i yeah it's
definitely gonna be one of those
comic dancers those are just gotta be
one of those because the comment the
thanos copter was pretty sweet
jonathan granadas again is the original
loki and he works for kang so that's
that's my big idea
kang gives him his kingdom in return for
his keeping his variants out of the way
kang is the time keeper so that that was
like my original theory
is that it's just one time keeper
keyboard it's king
ken created this illusion if you will of
uh
timekeepers and all that stuff and
so here okay another thing and
actually real quick pirate man thanks
for that super chat opening at the end
had to be in the quantum realm look at
the background yeah i know but it also
could be in space
i'm i'm like split on that right now but
yeah you're a hundred percent kind of
looks like dormammu more than
like the space yeah right time it looks
like it's kind of in space
but uh uh agreeing again coming to
superchat thank you um here's here's
like my
loki so the tva
or sorry the time keepers were physical
androids i feel like loki would just
create
illusions um right
kang who who can't create an illusion
because again he has no
powers would make androids loki would
make
illusions and the time timekeepers
quotes
are androids so to me that's another
push towards king
eliath that we saw today is another push
towards king the limbo
universe is another push towards king
there's so many pushes towards kang
that even if it is loki kang's still
behind that loki
right kang still in charge and
he either look he works for him or he's
letting loki do it because the other
loki's a pain in his butt
or something right um
that's kind of what i think mister
chicken lad thanks for that super chat
that's kind of what i think
i think that definitely has to be
kang behind it all whether they reveal
that it's kang in the castle
or if they reveal that it's loki i still
think it's king behind it all
uh the ship taken off by the castle
has the shape of democracy kang's
warship
well the sphinx is what kang
originally used to time travel in
hold on real fast
greg was texting me um so that's enough
that's another
what's that nothing i was answering my
chat
uh smith the sun i believe loki will use
tin pad and travel to the beginning of
infinity war to create a fake loki
protection for thanos
to kill while saving the original loki
and i hope that is true thanks for that
super chat
one other one and you mentioned this a
little bit when um
classic loki was talking about how he
managed to stay alive
is uh what happens if our loki did the
same thing
and existed through time and figured out
a way to take over
and become the loki so the loki in
charge of everything
is loki from the original avengers right
yeah
it's a big question that'd be a really
cool twist
it'd be cool to see that i don't know if
it's actually true or not that's
literally just like a that's kind of
grabbing a straw that'd be cool
yeah because obviously a loki thought to
do it so maybe our loki would have
thought to do it
that's true like why would it be
different
so um hold on one super chat and
greg and john are gonna jump in keegan
low the inside of the castle's not as
guardian look as guardian looking as
we've seen in the trailer is it possible
that king loki
is loki at the end of the series yeah
i really do think so ah
couldn't it be kang employing a variant
of vlogging for tva absolutely
thank you for that super chat uh okay
let's get these
these dudes in here uh
you know what chris you tweeted about it
and it's happening now
there it is so i'm gonna go into i'm
gonna create a new chat and get you in
it
okay all right fam family
hold up like get these nerds in here
it says they're not online
one two what am i hearing how do i
i don't even know how to i just want to
get rid of
me you really can't unfortunately yeah
it's gonna be what are my view options
here grid
side how do i show
i want to show it like where it just
shows the person that's talking i wonder
if it'll do that
we'll see but this is what we have so
far how dare you
[Music]
oh um they're
plugging live stream stuff in so ah yes
it's yellow jacket can you imagine he
freaking like
from the first film just like gets shot
at the quantum realm like
he does all of this that'd be crazy
thanks shane
what if one's ruling everything in
sylvia and loki from the future
and this is how they get there and the
story is a loop like the netflix series
i mean that's possible
when you start messing with time it
takes to mess back
things get confusing like they're all
talking about all their different time
variants the loki's and how this all
happened
you would assume that that means that
that exists for everybody the iron man
has all of these different variants that
have been pruned
and name a character right that would be
the assumption yeah
but the confusion behind it is
you know they're only gonna
hello wait oh no i lost chris
hello we did it we got all the people
you got all the people greg
john i hear them i don't believe speak
you cannot be heard
i don't hear them but they could be
joking
you're definitely definitely joking
speak for real you cowards
okay we can't hear them hold on fist
medio two and the scene
we see with king loki the other guy on
the right applauding him was a guy that
made a cameo in the first thor it's a
flashback oh i'll have to check that out
and thanks for that super chat let's
figure out why we can't hear the real
rejects
if we secretly muted them uh i don't
know
no i don't have them oh i hear them i
figured it out
it wasn't john for the time hey you did
it you're so good
so good the new it department how do i
turn them up so guys
uh let's click on the figure this is
figured it out was that guys
do you guys have any spider-man no way
home updates then
the trailer came out yesterday i don't
know if you guys caught that
toby and andrew inspired the elias mod
thing right
oh absolutely
yeah they were both like swept slinging
just inside that big cloud
a little bit you got to you got to tell
us what we need to talk about we need we
need to know everything that we need to
touch on
or else we've got the pad of paper ready
to go
like what have we got hey craig chris
you've never actually officially been
um no we haven't hello chris have you
guys not met
uh i think i met him the first time you
ever did a show briefly when i was
fixing your mic or something chris greg
and john greg and john chris
i met we never met we've never we've
never professionally met so hello i'm
chris from culture chris i'm also the
editor for the cosmic wonder
and all around decent dude telling lies
is this how you introduce yourself at
like family parties no i don't go to
those
they don't they don't invite me
for a cause i wonder i'm also a culture
one one's a little bit more exciting
than the other i'll let you determine
which one that
so okay this is gonna be good this is
gonna be great right so i have i have
greg and john
and i have freaking i have greg and john
and i have chris here
we're gonna talk about rape is crazy
you're right
and we're going to talk about what is it
roll call complete yeah right is it
king or loki who's behind it all
initial thoughts go loki i know what you
think
they don't no they do we were talking
about it before
i think it's loki because if they didn't
sylvia say that they're hiding
whoever's behind it is hiding behind
essentially a life is guard dog right
and then the fact that there's like you
know you throw a rock and you hit a loki
anywhere on this planet like this one
specific planet like a bunch of loki's
this strikes me like it would be a loki
john did you share that thought
i feel like i'm in a corner now because
well no man though c jenkins thank you
uh yeah i think maybe our loki is alive
you know city we saw it thanks for the
super
yeah yeah so i don't know i i feel like
yeah they are aiming for
some type of surprise and i
i don't believe a lot of things from
renzlaire but i think it would be
interesting if she actually doesn't know
as well
so uh i would be down with a with a
low-key reveal or something like that
yeah or even if they decide to go with
like the the one who remains or
something but i don't know
i just don't want to say kang right now
because it's the obvious answer it's the
actual time period well
well okay okay so here's what we'll do
then
chris is going to list his points for
for
for loki and i'll list my points for
kang and we can see if
if we've wooed you in any particular
direction or not so chris i'm gonna let
you start
i was looking for my my reasons but i
don't see them oh no i have a ton of
them um
put me on the spot now i'm scared i've
gotta impress these guys um
well basically my first big thought is
if we look at the um
if we look at the push of all of the
disney plus cassie make sure that super
chat i'll address one division ended
one division no big reveal falcon in the
winter soldier ended
falcon becoming captain america there
was no mutants in madrid
it all wrapped back in so that's where
the disney plus shows have been going
well you never know mephisto's still
there somewhere we just haven't found
him yet
i saw him he's he's he's hiding with
james gunn's last easter egg
um
um
but then on top of that you know it's
the loki's hate each other
loki's are narcissists loki's never get
along which was a huge theme in this
episode
about loki talking to sylvie and you
know the whole cuddling in the blanket
and we're still not sure if we want that
to happen or not although i'm for it
um if two loki's even like each other it
causes a nexus event that will destroy
the tva
right so this loki who is the superior
loki another quote we've heard the
entire time has sought out to destroy
any traces of loki's in order to remain
the superior loki to be the best of the
loki's
and i don't know i just think it's
possible kang although very powerful one
of the most powerful characters in the
comics
is aware of the tva can't do anything
until the tva crumbles
and i was just saying to warren before
you guys entered maybe the post-credits
scene at the very end after all the
credits are done after that even is
kang watching the tva crumble smiling
and
doing something to demonstrate that he's
coming to power
but those are kind of my top top little
points there's a bunch but
go ahead warren
it's solid points
how do i get him out of this call get
out of here
uh well here's so okay here's my deal
there's so many connections to kang
in this series that it's just it would
be so weird
if he wasn't behind at all i'm not
saying that loki actually couldn't be
behind at all because maybe
kang employed a loki and he's like i
will make you king loki i will give you
power over everything
right and as you can see there's a
billion variants of you right if you
just keep them in line
maybe that's the whole point because you
know they talked about there's more loki
variants than almost any other variant
out there so
but here here's basically what i have to
say um
sorry i'm screen shotting super chat so
i don't miss them so i can address them
after so
if you just think about everything
wikipedia that is wikipedia
okay so but but i'm just going to list
off all the things that like connection
the king
okay the tva is associated with king
time travel is associated with king greg
i told you this before i don't know if
you told john
um the time
i'm listening i just gotta i gotta
export this video
you're fine you're fine you know what
let me address some super chats let me
address some super chats real fast i'll
give you i'll give you a second
so first super chat
uh pvt backflip thank you loki shows up
removing them from this world
comic uh yeah i wouldn't be surprised
that happens
uh kazzy wuzzy what if the tva
and all the pruning and stuff was made
by loki to find a loki powerful enough
to take over and prevent king to control
time oh this is a
this is like a a combination of one
uh loki loki
it's kind of like loki would know kang
is coming and he's trying to like
he's trying to take over everything to
prevent kang from coming
so like there is a low key that's like
the one above all loki but he
he he's trying to prevent kang from
coming which is why he's taking over
that's an interesting thought i think
that super chat uh vasil wilcox i think
it's jk i think it's king loki
i'm gonna pull back the mephisto's and
i'm gonna go back to mephisto and say
it's mephisto
imagine this whole time that actually is
that'd be insane wouldn't it be funny
uh c jenkins thanks for the super chat
hi
can i i want her to pose a question
john's right there
uh i you know how you're saying how so
much of your theory
of the of how it just seems like it
should be king to conquer
it all links to that i
i'm likely to agree with that because of
comics lore and all that
but i think that's the reason why you
are are really
dead set on that and why i think a lot
of us are dead set on it same reason why
we were a lot of us were believing it
could be right
i think for this specific story they're
telling though
it just it would feel a little left
field if we get to the final episode and
then they got to introduce king the
conqueror all of a sudden
story-wise i think yeah
structurally to have it be loki another
loki because there's been
no re the only hints about king the
conqueror are things
you've picked up on and others because
of comics
in terms of the show itself nothing
about king to conquer if that makes
sense you know what i mean
sure you feel a little feel a little
lappy
yeah no i would agree with you
to mephisto
in the mcu hell is not like actual hell
it's just another dimensional
place and think of it hell as a great
big
beastly dog thing guarding the door i'm
going my fist though
you heard it here first got one in for
my fist you heard it here first
and there it is uh loki shark loki
mark loki so
i i would i agree with you greg i i
agree with you and i'm just
taking pictures of these super chats i
agree with you but here's
here's my rebuttal to that
with one division it really was
okay with one of vision it really was
like we were grasping at straws
like we we thought devils and details
but fisto
you know what i mean like we it made
sense because we
made it make sense right if that
if that makes sense um we were looking
for it and granted i am looking for kang
but i'm looking for kang because in the
comics
a huge association to the tva a big
association to the timekeepers
and immortus right so the story i told
you and the comics
what what moby has talked about what
rinslayer talked about is that
at the there's an end of time that
hasn't been written yet right
that void is like the end of time in the
comics
and again yes it's comics but the three
time keepers
again kang timekeepers tva timekeepers
they are
the last living beings of the universe
in general and they go to kang and they
say hey
just so you know in the future down the
line there's only three of us left so
instead of conquering worlds how about
you start saving them
and return will make you immortal he
says yes
and he becomes a mortise right so again
timekeepers
coming back talking to kang king being
in charge ravana red slayers king's
lover in the comics
she is kind of against him at first but
then falls in love with him which
could kind of be what we're seeing here
um
and then now eliath is king is
that's directly related to gang in the
comics so is the world that they're in
right now limbo that's where cranopolis
is
in the comics king's base right so
there's
i mean that's all like factual things
that have been mentioned
like we know it's ravana rensselaer
that's her name the timekeepers
they're the timekeepers right uh the
limbo dimension that's what they talked
about elia they said that by name you
get what i'm saying like it's not like
i'm looking for
the devil and the details these are
actual things that have been said
all right now let me rebuttal because
wanda vision is not just
little details there was agatha harkness
in there
which are all very mephisto heavy
yeah i believe that yeah i mean if it's
king the conqueror i wouldn't be
surprised
like i'm not gonna be like oh [ __ ] oh
what the hell was i thinking
i i think it wouldn't be a surprise uh
like i i mean i'd be down for it i would
be down for it
um we're just playing a game of the
theoretical because that's what we
don't talk about the action what's yeah
what's next right
that episode's over let's talk about
something else
let's talk about the future episode uh
yeah i think it would be um
i don't know i feel like i was on the
kang train mainly
up until like a little bit before this
episode started where i
was it was where i was pretty much at
when we did when we hopped in on your
pre
on the pre i was i was a little bit
there you make solid points though like
there
are so many things to set it up and king
the conqueror is coming into
ant-man batman so we know king is coming
um and and then we had um you know even
you know feige himself
at the disney event was like king the
conqueror
that's who he's playing so like get to
know who this guy is because he's coming
right you know
there are things that i would i could
say to help support uh
reasoning for why it could be king to
conquer too um but yeah we'll set the
way and see i'll have to wait
i i i will have to say
yeah i would have to say that i'm
actually
leaning more towards what you like kind
of what you just said actually because
like
in in terms of like before i was
definitely huge kang train
and now i'm like well it
i kind of feel like it actually is
pushing a little bit more towards like a
king loki
oh yeah yeah yeah 100 yeah yeah boys
no i didn't say i do think it's well
that i i said it it's pushed more
towards it in this last episode
but i still think there's a crap ton of
evidence from from a personal
perspective that would be pretty
interesting because
think about it like loki if his glorious
purpose is to
dictate all choices for everyone and
rule
that's like the most extreme and
superlative way to do it is to create
some kind of time
authority that locks people into a
timeline and
like there's in that first episode you
show how loki
how his own ideology that you know his
villainous ideology that he's pushing on
people in the first avengers movie is
then like
flipped back around on him you know kind
of be a parallel to
what the tva does in general and that's
what wakes our loki up to it so maybe
the
kind of grand twist could be that it is
like one continuing that theme of like
confronting a character
literally by making it confront
different versions of itself
yeah i mean think about it too because
like it's been
this loki whoever the following has had
such a massive character arc
oh so big yeah in no time
yeah it's just in new york and now he's
like you know i realized i was a shitty
human being i kind of love this sylvie
he completely has so shifted
lately and i don't know how i honestly
don't know how some people feel about
that
sense of like in this episode they have
just made him
a hero so i think it would be cool if
the big baddie is still a loki villain
and i think that could also work too
because then if they confront this
situation and deal with it that could
just leave the universal door wide open
for kang to spin and take control
yeah yeah um
yeah well and going back to something
you said greg before
i do feel like it would be a lot
if we like to throw kang in there at the
end
it would be right because it
is the final episode you're just going
to throw this
character that nobody has any idea who
they are
right i mean i but at the same time
they're they're searching for the
timekeeper
right they're searching for who's behind
it so at the same time it wouldn't be
huge if they were like oh this is can
conquer guess what i
discovered time travel way into the
future and i discovered how to control
it that's all you really have to say
i'm king the master of time i created
this blah blah blah
blah there's not much really you need to
dive deep into it
right but at the same time it's still
a lot to throw in there at the end
what if the show just completely doesn't
even give us
well that's always fun i could see that
happening
don't do that the post credit stage
outside the text of the show but like
when i watch loki episodes
uh like i don't know i feel like yeah
there is a certain element
of like the the breadth of
references and canon characters to keep
up with i
i know firsthand can be a little
overwhelming for
people who don't keep up with this and
theorize it's the way that we do so yeah
i could see them not wanting to
overwhelm people with a
random yeah what would seem like a
random because it's not gonna you're not
gonna be attached to kang if you're just
yeah you know hey oh a random big bad
guy
who will eventually learn it's like in
terms of like storytelling
the reveal would be i feel like it just
pure storytelling format i think the
reveal will be a little bit
weak if it's like we've been looking for
the reveal all
these episodes and it's someone we've
never seen somewhere
yeah yeah usually in a situation like
this it would be something that
even if you haven't read the comics the
audience everything's like oh i should
have seen the clues coming you know what
i mean like having an audience who's
coming
and it's king if they haven't read the
you gotta just like kind of because
they're subscribed to
you guys and warren and they know
because they watch the videos
every viewer of loki watches
[Music]
that's what kevin feige was hoping when
he was in the in the drawing room he's
like well we got warren we got
greg and john you know they'll explain
it
it's okay and real quick to everybody
everybody in the chat i will address the
super chats so don't think i'm just
ignoring them but we'll address them in
a bit
um the one the one thing i think is for
certain moving into the final episode is
the tva is mis dismantled
right regardless of whoever's in charge
of it whether they die and they're
destroyed or it's their reveal
or you know loki kills them and takes
over however that ends
the tva is going to be dismantled and
that's going to start the cracks for
spider-man
and then eventually the madness for
multiverse of madness and
that alone i am very very very excited
for
yeah very very like the future upcoming
year of marvel is going to be
a wild ride yeah this does set the
premise for spider-man home and
multiverse of madness and
i'm gonna say kang even if he's not
revealed
it definitely has to do something with
kang right it has to have something to
do with him
yeah regardless the way how it has
something to do with
faulty versus madness and spider-man
this clearly has something to do at
least with next ant-man
oh for sure yeah you know well it's all
over and that's
time yeah and that's what they said
going into this kevin feige said this is
the most
important show to the future of the mcu
that we're going to have seen it's going
to set up phase 4 in ways that nothing
else really has so
all of that's there as well and i just
we have a lot to be excited for
yeah definitely he also said that you
don't even need to watch calkin and
winter soldier you don't even
watch one you're probably okay without
those yeah
yeah don't don't watch them you know
don't even watch them who cares
just watch loki
our whole mcu future is riding off of
what if
oh man all right we should we should we
should get going it's building our
review and i got it like
yeah work on the edits yep same here
yeah
what do we have to talk about
what what should we stop what must we
talk about what are the bullet points
what are the main
points to talk about
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you guys failed he is the copter
[Music]
yeah he's the copter and the dashboard
has slots for all the infinity stones
and i don't know how many people did
catch it but there in the back during
the scene when all the loki's were
fighting there was a tv
and on the tv actually was the spiderman
home trailer
good night everybody
that was chris
all right guys we got work to do it was
a pleasure actually getting to hang out
with you guys
yeah it was it was
it was mutual it was an experience it
was
oh look at that look
chris and john are variants of each
other
all right guys go work go work we'll do
the same have a good night guys
see you guys
okay i'm addressing all the super chats
now and i'm sorry
that uh what is happening where's my
camera up there you are
okay so sorry for the delay and
addressing all the super chats but i
hope
everybody uh i hope everybody enjoyed
those
um vinnie thanks for super chat
after silvia asked loki not to turn on
her i think he truly has one more trick
up his sleeve
and he's in fact behind it all i don't
know if our loki knows that he's behind
it all but i do think he has trick up a
sleeve see jenkins thanks for the
another super chat screen culture
episode 6 trailer king confirmed uh
those are fan
made they make those themselves so i'd
be very careful
with uh with what you believe from that
dante dreamer thanks for that super chat
classic
loki's story tells us what happened to
our loki he casted himself to die
then went hit on a planet you know i i i
totally believe that could be true
a hundred percent uh classic thanks for
that super chat eliath is king's
creation
rinse layers king's love the company in
the avengers tower is associated with
king
but it's loki question mark come on now
it's king period yeah i shouldn't be
letting these guys distract me
and get me off the king train because it
really freaking seems like it's king
right
elijah wood kng enterprises that was on
the side of the avengers building is ran
by mr griffin
aka nathaniel richards from earth 6 3 1
1 aka a version of king absolutely
and that will definitely be in the
breakdown and that's another point
yeah that's another thing pointing us in
direction okay thanks for that super
chat
uh the santos it's 2012 avengers tower
all over or avenged all over again eva
loki who works for kang
gets beaten then king has to i'll do it
myself
scene boom phase four baby that's
actually freaking sweet i hope that
happens
uh thanks for that super chat
dada smithy winkle thanks for super chat
read marvel's bio for a life it
literally states that it rests on the
edge of kings from chronopolis yep
absolutely um not denying that
connection
at all whatsoever uh let me just
get one here so i don't
lose it danny bella what if king has
been prevented from rising to power by
the tva
at the end of loki is what allows him to
begin his conquest yeah
it would be cool if we see like more of
an origin story for him rather than he's
already in control
and thanks for that super chat moving
back to some other super chats
uh eastern shore shooter 25 it is either
kang loki or doctor doom most likely
doctor jim kame won't be introduced
until 2023
yeah but i don't think king or doom is
going to be introduced for a while
although i'll
i'll give it to you that it really did
look like doom castle
uh thomas cough colfin coffin
thanks for super chat it's trevor the
actor playing a fake kang
there you go uh
let's see making sure i don't miss any
pvt backflip y'all think they will
change story comic or woke uh
no uh i don't think this has been too
woke um you know and if you consider the
fact that loki is bisexual in the comics
nothing nothing's wrong i don't know i
like it the way everything's gone so far
uh demon05 even if kang isn't in the
series we know he's coming so he's
involved in this no matter what just by
default yeah
absolutely totally agree and thanks for
that super chat
um classic thanks for another super chat
avengers tower
said king on this company owned by
nathanael richards
too much kang for not to be him yes i
agree
yogi thanks for that super chat eliath
is the temporal being that escapes
kang's ring
the cloud parts away we can see a castle
over a
silvery stream which we have seen earl
in earlier trailers
the silvery stream is mostly the sacred
timeline
the castle is mostly chronopolis
i could agree with that i could
definitely agree with that and i think i
am all caught up with the ones i took
screenshots of samantha gray
castle limbo and it will introduce
amoris castle limbo
fits perfectly okay
uh yes because i mean
i can't say yes definitively but yes
because they're in limbo
so it just makes sense right uh yeah i
can't really argue with that
um gamer potheads kang what about the
one who sits above
in the shadows um i just think there's a
lot to like too much
pointing towards kang like specifically
related to kang
ravana renslayer the timekeepers uh
limbo i just think there's so much
pointing towards king
you know um so we'll have to see on that
i think i got all the super chats and if
i didn't i
deeply apologize to any i might have
missed
um i'm looking through them all here and
it looks like i got them all but again
i'm so sorry if i missed them
i just didn't want to enter i didn't
want to interrupt the guests
on my show uh see jenkins toby ninja
confirmed from this episode right
i mean i think the whole thing confirms
uh you know i i think the whole thing
confirms them so i'm gonna say yeah
and uh thank you so much for all the
super chats you've given me tonight
um yeah so guys i'm gonna go ahead and
say stop the super chats because
my stream is a little bit delayed from
what you hear
and i don't want to miss any super chats
i greatly appreciate everybody stopping
by tonight everybody watching
um and i
think it's king i think loki could be
behind it but kang would be behind loki
right if so if anything really
happened like that at the end i i
definitely
you know just with the with the time
everything with the time i think it's
you know i think you think it's just
kang yeah chocolate thunder too much
easter eggs for it not to be king i mean
yeah
right it's just so many uh greg made a
good point though
and chris makes good points too about it
being loki but i i still think
even if loki is at the top of it kang's
behind him
and that's my final thought so we're
gonna
get to work because it's 2 44 for me
almost three am so probably be getting
to bed at like eight o'clock in the
morning tonight but no worries because
it's worth it
to get my breakdown out hope you all
enjoyed loki
uh be sure to like this video and let me
know in this video's
chat what you rate the episode
i think it's best so far i personally
really enjoyed a lot of it
um but see that this episode of last
episode was the best
so
yeah so we'll see there's a lot of cool
things breakdown in this episode i'm
really excited to break it down my voice
is going away i need to save it for my
breakdown
excuse me so i'm gonna go ahead
and um i'm gonna go ahead and in the
stream
now mr anderson thanks so much for being
an awesome mod everybody give it up for
him
and i
the whoever put the thought of
it's like a thanos like the first loki
was working for thanos and now this loki
is working for king
i think that's super cool
and i think that would be great so
thank you thank you everybody stop by
thank you to everybody who just watched
in the background thank you to everybody
who chatted thank you everybody who gave
me super chats i love you all
so much and you make this job a lot of
fun and you make this job possible so
thank you very much for that
because uh without you guys i wouldn't
be here so thank you all
i love you all and i'll see you tomorrow
in my video and the next week for the
finale
of loki so i'll see you guys next time
woof